i have very much enjoy this show it's so
much fun to watch all of the craziness
that goes on on the show
and i'm curious i mean could you ever
have imagined that you would say huzzah
so many times on one job i mean does
somebody keep like a running counter per
season
no but we should be sure
they counted up the amount of glasses we
broke in the first season didn't they
and yeah what was it it was into the
hundreds yeah a lot yeah yeah but the
huzzah i mean it becomes like a twitch
after a while you've so we've said it so
many times you can wake yourself up in
the middle of the night
but i love it because it can mean so
many different things you know it has
you can use it in so many different
contexts you know and that's that's um
yeah it's brilliant at first i remember
you know when we first started shooting
you know it took a while to get used to
just to saying hazard to feel like it
was something you would just you would
say and now it just you know there's a
seamless system now that's quite it's
quite fun yeah yeah do you find that you
have to actually stop saying it in real
life because people just look at you
like it's crazy
it is it's very expressive it's a great
word to say it kind of like says like
you say it can mean lots of different
things so yeah i do find myself saying
it quite a lot
these characters are all so big and bold
and over the top do you miss playing
them in between seasons or is it a
character that you're happy to pack away
and take a bit of a break from
i i
really look forward to the opportunity
to do it again because it is so much fun
to play in these parts
um
but then at the same time you know
it's good to have a break and do
something different isn't it and yeah
and kind of challenge yourself in
different ways so yeah and also you know
they're
they're not the nicest people really i
mean
grigor and rkd are they've got their
faults haven't they yeah kind of not
massively sympathetic characters so it's
good to walk away from that something
how about for you about
um yeah no it's similar to what gulen
just said i think um
it's
you look forward to playing these
characters because they're just so much
fun to play and it's just you know the
writing is just incredible so it's you
know it's it's a treat to be able to
work with that text um but it's also
nice to you know have a break and and
have that
opportunity to look forward to going
back to it you know so so you know
balance
it seems like all of the characters on a
show like this aside from maybe
catherine and peter
might be a little bit like you might not
have known too much about them when you
started it seems like there's so much
room for them to grow
so what did you actually know about who
your character would be and is has
anything really surprised you about them
since then yeah so i think when we when
we started didn't really know
too much because they're not based on
real people so they're you know entirely
fictional but um
i you know i had a chat with with tony
about you know character and potential
arts and where it's going but we we
don't get all the episodes um when we
start filming we get them as you go
along so you're con it's con it's a
constant discovery um
but that's also quite nice you know it's
nice to
to be surprised and to be um and to
figure stuff out along the way like
relationships or bits of history between
characters that you didn't you know know
existed and you haven't been preset or
tried to play that in some way it's just
it just is and that's uh that's always
that's quite nice
about the way we make this show
so that's the really the really rich
thing about this season isn't it is that
like the first season is a big it's it's
a lot about setup and it's a lot about
like kind of
uh establishing who these characters are
and what this world is but now that we
know that at the end of season one we
can jump straight back in uh into the
deep end with season two and like it
allows you the opportunity in this
season to really explore
like some different depths to these
characters and explore like a bit more
of the kind of human side of them all i
think yeah sure
yeah i mean
griego is
in a very interesting position with his
wife and his best friend and
he doesn't seem to really you know
that's not really the situation you want
to be in in a marriage
so
why
do you think he puts up with what he
does for as long as he has what's it
like to play someone like thing and
explore that
yeah i mean it's um
why does he put up with it i mean
because he has to really uh
you know
to to stand up against someone like
peter is dangerous he's he's a
petulant kind of dangerous violent man
so you don't stand up to him
um but equally i think he doesn't
stand up to him because he ultimately
loves him he loves pizza he's completely
loyal to him and it's not about like
political positioning for gregor i don't
think it is just a matter of like
uh
you know connection and love so that's
really put to the test in season two um
you know who's he gonna choose who's
greek are gonna choose his wife or or
peter and it's uh it's very interesting
who he does choose in the end
um
but also it's like you know that that's
what i find very interesting about this
this shows and this world is that like
there's no space there's no space for
privacy in this core you know it's a
really kind of intense pressure cooker
situation everyone's living on top of
each other in this very small
environment and like it's very difficult
to have
feelings and to to kind of like
to deal with your feelings in this world
um
yeah
what do you think those two
relationships say about him as a
character i mean how how does that
define him for you as far as
how he is with both of those people in
his life
sorry sorry about how grigor is with
with him between his wife and
peter
yeah yeah what's it say about grigor
yeah i mean how do you how does he that
inform him for you i mean does it does
do you think about that as far as you
know the choices you make
yeah i think um i think ultimately you
know it proves that he's a loyal he's a
very loyal person you know
um
he is loyal he tries to be loyal to both
his wife and
and his best friend and that's what puts
him in this predicament so he's kind of
like pretty
i know he's got a lot of faults griggle
but he's actually
quite decent in that sense i think
that's one of his qualities one of his
virtues
why wouldn't you enjoy about arcadia and
the relationship that he has with people
i mean he sort of seems to
be able to
kind of move around among everybody
um
yeah i mean i feel like he's definitely
firmly in um you know peter's camp
um but also i suppose he's also quite
cognizant and aware of like i suppose
his position within that camp and
although he's a close friend of peter's
he's um
you know he's he's aware that like
he doesn't necessarily say have the the
history and um lifelong friendship that
he has with grigor so he's quite aware
of that and i suppose um it's a similar
thing with um the relationship he has
with um his wife tatiana played by
florence cliffroche i think um they're
both quite aware of that and there's
they're they're
a family you know so there's an element
of
um the choices they make being aligned
with the element of like
self-preservation for themselves and
their family and yeah so it's quite
interesting and fun to this season uh
was quite fun to do because you you get
to see a bit more of his like uh sort of
mac available inside and scheming side
which is lots of fun to do i thought it
was funny that he's sort of the one that
has gone to for relationship advice too
because everybody's relationship is
pretty much a mess on the show
yeah yeah and he's the founding man so
you know
he's just about looking at himself to be
honest
well this show is visually stunning the
costumes are incredible
the sets seem so detailed what do you
think would most surprise viewers when
it comes to every detail and what it
takes to pull off a show like this
um
i'm such a fan of the of the creative
team of the show i'm constantly talking
about like the costume the set design
because i come to set and i'm like wow
this is just incredible it's amazing and
i think that um
i think like with every department just
like we can say with the act with that
acting department with actors you know
you come into the second season kind of
get knowing the world and getting the
gist of it and you can just be a bit
more expressive and creative um coming
into it for a second season i think that
um is true across the board and i think
that like everyone just sees in the
second season really just steps it up or
not so i think there's a lot of
exciting and surprising um things for
audiences to to take in in in that
regard
so it's that incredible attention to
detail as well as it's like yeah you
know and i think it's the specificity
that really gives this show a richness
and allows you to really connect with it
it's like
there's never just a party a generic
party there's always something specific
in particular about it yeah um so like
there's a in one of the episodes there's
a baby shower and uh they kind of you
you read that in the scripture like
they're a baby shower you kind of don't
think too much about it or imagine what
that is and then you turn up to set on
the day that we're shooting and they've
created this world this mad crazy
eccentric world where we're all kind of
dressed up in these weird kind of like
child like costumes and colors and we've
got elaborate wigs on and stuff and it's
like
that's what makes
what makes it so kind of eccentric and
and kind of brilliant and i think it's
what audiences hopefully really connect
with as well yeah yeah it feels like
there are so many little details on the
sets that you guys can see that we
probably can't even see as the viewers
but it changes how
you act or how you move and it's just
it's
so detailed and incredible to watch in
that way
definitely because you know it's all
there for you to interact with and play
with and just be be a part of and and so
that detail definitely informs the way
you play because you're just you you tap
into that world very readily very
quickly because it's all there for you
to just interact with and so and the
costumes and the makeup everything just
sort of informs the way you move through
the space which is um just lots of fun i
think we're also really encouraged to
like not wear these clothes as like
costumes but imagine them as our actual
clothing so there's we're always in a
various state of undress we're yeah you
know we're kind of like we're very
rarely like in some period dramas you
see everyone's very kind of like put
together and the wigs are perfect like
stuff and and so and
quite often we're not wearing our wigs
they're kind of like thrown on a table
so and and our shirts are undone and you
know we've got um
we've got our jackets off and all that
kind of stuff and it kind of like
creates the
creates that world of like anarchy and
and kind of chaos a little bit i suppose
yeah and it's a and there's a lot of
collaboration as well because it's like
an ongoing dialogue between you and and
say cost you more makeup about you know
what your character would be wearing in
the scene and how they would be wearing
it would they be a bit more relaxed
would they be a bit more primitive in
those scenes there are scenes where
you're a bit more relaxed and i'm
probably a bit more prominent proper
than that you know that's you know i
think speaks to say arcady be you know
wanting to say climb up a little power
or wanting to like you know you know be
impressive quite a lot and that's that's
a conversation that's constantly
happening between us and costumers and
makeup and it's um
it's nice because like you say you don't
then you don't feel like you're wearing
a costume you just feel like you're
wearing your own clothes you know yeah
so that's um
yeah it's great well it's so much fun to
watch and get to live in very briefly so
thank you for talking to me about it
thanks very much